the prologue of the movie mentions a
date 5th of August 2020 on this day
scientists at an undisclosed research
facility celebrate the creation of the
world's first man-made black hole why
then we see two scientists James and
Anna who were part of the black hole
Mission they talk about an unexpected
incident which they initially considered
to be a glitch but hours later a cosmic
disruption has triggered worldwide
blackouts within 24 hours the sudden
appearance of mysterious black portals
creates Widespread Panic and numerous
people go missing as a result massive
uations begin in the major cities
scientists should have seen this coming
the scene then cuts to 3 Days After the
Blackout and we are introduced to a man
named Adam Reed his wife Andrea and
their daughter Kate who reside in
Lancaster California after learning
about the escalating worldwide surge the
family decides to leave the city and
relocate to somewhere safe while driving
through a deserted Countryside Road a
black portal appears out of nowhere
causing their car to crash into it
following this we are taken back to 3
hours After the Blackout at a call
center in Washington DC people keep on
calling 911 reporting their panic over
the portals the call operators Kathy
Stan Dory Robert and Larry are trying
their best to calm the people down
through the calls but the emergency
support services are already overloaded
amidst this chaos Dory requests her
Superior Cathy for permission to leave
because she hasn't been able to contact
her 7-year-old daughter since the
blackout however Kathy denies her
request claiming that they need her
there as The Operators continue
addressing frantic callers the power
suddenly goes out moments later a black
portal appears in the middle of the call
room freaking everyone out all of them
try to escape but they are unable to
unlock the door Stan who is a mentally
unstable conspiracy theorist seems to be
mesmerized and delighted to see the
portal he slowly approaches the portal
and focuses on the sound that is
emanating from it suddenly Stan reveals
that both he and Cathy had received
calls about these black portals years
ago upon inquiring they found out that
the numbers were untraceable despite
this he became so curious about this
mystery and has been collecting
information regarding the portals ever
since so what have you learned Stan
nothing helpful in the midst of this
startling Revelation Stan slowly walks
back and grabs a gun which he then aims
at his fellow workers it appears that
the portal is telepathically
communicating with him as he mentions
that the voice wants everyone to enter
it no one agrees to comply San shoots
Robert as their first warning in a state
of panic Larry agrees to go first he
reluctantly walks up to the portal and
touches it causing him to be sucked in
Stan then asks Dory to go next in order
to convince her he claims that her
daughter is already on the other side of
the portal which is is the reason why
she isn't able to contact her Cathy
Whispers to Dory not to go and secretly
hands her some scissors to attack him
Dory then approaches the portal and
abruptly stabs Stan but unfortunately in
the process she is shot and killed
unable to convince anyone further Stan
himself decides to enter the portal but
it does not let him pass instead the
portal blames him for the chaos which
breaks him down in a fit of rage he
pulls out his gun and shoots towards the
portal however the it Ricochet and kills
him on the spot in the aftermath the
rest of the call operators fall under
the Portal's mind control prompting them
to enter it one after another by the
time the SWAT team arrives for their
rescue everyone is gone how about that
response time in the next scene we see
Adam who wakes up in a hospital room
with one eye bandaged he gets off his
bed and walks around but all the doors
and windows are locked not long after a
nurse named Leslie approaches him and
asks him to go back to his bed Adam asks
about his family to which she replies
that they are fine Leslie also tells him
that he is the first person who has come
back alive from the portal this confuses
Adam because she just mentioned that his
family is fine she somehow manages to
get him back to bed and goes to call the
doctor shortly after Dr marinan enters
the wardro and checks Adam's eyes after
a brief inspection the doctor concludes
that Adam's left eye is suffered
irreparable damage due to the accident
as a result they must perform surgery to
remove Adam's left eye and replace it
with a prosthetic lens afterwards while
performing the surgery the doctors are
shocked to witness Adam's once blue eyes
transform into an abysal pitch black Hue
the scene then cuts to Jakarta Indonesia
precisely 3 minutes before the blackout
event we see two sisters Sarah and Jill
walking towards their car in a Shopping
Center's parking lot during this Jill
gives her sister the good news that she
is pregnant but Sarah who is still
grappling with the profound grief of
losing her own child starts arguing with
Jill claiming that she doesn't want to
be an ant doesn't matter what you guys
feeling here come the holes in the
middle of their argument the power
suddenly goes out and Jill vanishes for
a moment a short while later she
reappears in a shocked State and asks
Sarah to follow her within seconds the
other Shoppers within the vicinity who
are under the control of an unseen Force
show up in the parking lot as well Jill
leads them towards the portal and says
that it is calm ing them she also says
that the portal is promising to give
anything they want in their lives
especially if what they want is nothing
just then Sarah hears the crying voice
of a baby frightened she starts shouting
at the people trying to break the trance
they're all in she also pulls Jill away
from the portal causing her to fall and
hit her head on the ground this sudden
injury snaps Jill out of her unconscious
State at the same time they witness an
entranced mother Wheeling her baby
toward the portal it speaks its first
word
existential nothingness a few moments
later the woman realizes what she has
done and tries to follow her baby
through the portal however she is
violently repelled back resulting in her
immediate demise following this the rest
of the people start entering the portal
one by one the Two Sisters gripped by
Terror attempt to flee the scene but
some people in the parking lot become
increasingly aggressive and launch
attacks against them at one point Sarah
hides her injured sister behind a pillar
and goes to retrieve her car as soon as
she gets in the car an entranced woman
breaks through the window and attacks
her but despite the odds Sarah manages
to summon the strength to fight back she
then rescues Jill and starts driving
away however before they can exit the
parking lot Jill again becomes entranced
and forces the car to drive towards the
portal following this the car is
engulfed by a blinding flash of white
light emanating from the Portal's door
suddenly Sarah gets ejected through the
windshield should have buckled up and
finds herself in an empty parking lot
confused and filled with fear she
frantically searches the parking lot
desperately calling out for her sister
shortly after she finds Jill who is
holding a baby Jill passes the baby to
Sarah and then inexplicably vanishes
from the scene Sarah is unable to
understand what is going on but she
proceeds to calm the crying baby the
screen then pans out revealing that she
is now inside the portal on the other
hand Adam is seen talking to Leslie who
inquires about his eyes and his overall
well-being Adam tells her that he feels
uncomfortable with the lens as it is new
to him afterwards when he is alone in
his hospital room curiosity prompts him
to inspect his operated on eye he then
unwraps the bandage and looks at his
eyes in the mirror to his shock he
discovers that his left eye has turned
completely black at that moment a
strange voice addresses him saying that
the doctor doctors are lying about his
family frustrated and anxious Adam
confronts Leslie demanding an
explanation on why he can't see his
family but she simply leaves without
offering any Clarity later Dr marinan
comes to check Adam's eye as soon as he
flashes a flashlight on his eye it
starts shining like the portal door
itself Adam tries to maintain his
composure but when the doctor takes too
long he pushes him away sensing that
something is a Miss Adam asks if he did
this to his eye Dr Markin finally
reveals that the new eye provides
insight into realities Beyond human
comprehension however the doctor claims
that Adam doesn't deserve such a gift
and proceeds to cut out his eye this
leads to them engaging in a brawl and
the doctor soon gains the upper hand he
is about to mutilate Adam's eye when
Leslie shoots Dr Markin from behind
Leslie then discloses that Adams as well
as her families are still on the other
side of the portal according to her Adam
is the only one who man managed to
return alive from there this is the
reason why Dr marinan was experimenting
on Adam to find out about the dark doors
she believes that Adam is the only
person who can bring their families back
but the latter has no recollection of
the Past after this Leslie leads Adam to
a portal door in another wing of the
hospital and tells him that he must
enter it to rescue their family as Adam
approaches the portal it emits a
high-pitched sound Leslie unable to
endure the sound suffers a violent fate
as her head Burns bursts nevertheless
Adam gathers enough courage and enters
into the portal that teleports him to
the middle of a deserted Road after
walking for a while Adam arrives at a
building containing jail cells as he
proceeds deeper into the building he
notices his own dead body in one of the
cells which leaves him confused and
Disturbed before long the sound of his
daughter's voice calling out reaches his
ears he quickly follows the sound to
another cell only to find himself
mysteriously transported into a house
much much to his shock he finds Kate
there who is already grown up into a
teen however she doesn't recognize him
and runs away Adam tries to follow her
but he is once again transported this
time into a room with a large mirror
inside this room he encounters a
mirrored version of himself which asks
him to take a seat the mirror image
explains that this is the future where
Adam is no longer alive and his daughter
is living her life happily without him
unable to comprehend the situation the
real Adam asks his other version to
explain everything in detail the
reflection tells him that they see the
world through Adam's eyes while he lives
on their side then it offers Adam two
choices replace his other eye with a
portal and reunite with his family or
give back the new eye and die with no
other choice Adam accepts the first
option following this decision the
mirror version asks Adam to close his
eyes for a moment upon reopening them
Adam finds himself standing in front of
his house he Peaks through the portal
door hole and sees his wife and daughter
waiting for him but before letting him
in the mirrored version asks for his eye
in accordance with their agreement in a
startling twist Adam instead rips out
both of his eyes sabotaging the deal but
also his eyes the scene then shifts back
to the real world where Adam is seen in
the hospital after the car accident
Leslie takes Andrea and Kate to the
hospital room where he is admitted Adam
seems to have finally recovered but he
is completely blind now finally after a
prolonged separation Adam is reunited
with his family the scene then cuts to 3
months after the blackout in the UK
where James and Anna are conducting the
teleportation experiment using the
portals they have connected two portals
to teleport from one place to another
Anna is in a park while James is in the
research lab she enters the portal and
successfully ends up in the lab this
makes them happy believing that the
first stage of their experiment worked
out encouraged by this they proceed to
the second stage in which James enters
the portal followed by an he safely
reaches the other side but she arrives
only after a while moreover there's a
black liquid streaming down from her
eyes Anna who is now entranced holds
James's face and brutally melts it down
the movie ends with Anna announcing that
the portals are just the beginning of
the end subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching